foreign
[Music]
they had the choice of releasing a
marine or releasing Brittany Griner no
yeah there was a marine he was charged
with Espionage he's probably a better
basketball player
Jamie can you look up what Britney's
averaging this season to see if it was
worth it
it just started how's she doing she got
eight in her first game she got eight
points I think she got I think the
[__] leading scorer
I could smell bear sorry
sick say it again
you can smell Bear yeah yeah you think
you've got that Keen of a sense of smell
oh I know I know bear
I know better what does it smell like it
smells like wolf
but like heftier
and a heavy wolf you think a bear is a
heavy wolf
they have similar smells is this one of
your Chinese calendars no because it's
like no big I'll tell you why though
I'll be real I can smell a beer because
I know what wet dog smells like well
that I know you so you know right that's
not what a bear smells it does it's in
the snow it's hair wet hair you can
smell it I'm like Daredevil
no I have senses man
yeah you've got the regular ones no I
have extra smelling scents you think you
have an extra chromosome yeah dude I
can't hear that well or C but it all
went into my [__] noise
why would they have a Down syndrome
okay good very good one very good you
don't think you could smell bear no I
can't smell a [__] bear my father I
was smoking cigarettes 13 years old
smoking cigarettes a front seat of his
car you let me smoke cigarettes and he
goes you know what's good about you you
never smoke them down to the filter
okay
he goes You Never Smoke him down to the
end because that's what's good about you
it's an amazing
so these are the types you got to
internalize like that is what's good
yeah he's like you never smoke and he
goes That's what's good about you and I
threw him out the window and he goes you
know and that's like a picture like
other kids talking about what kids like
what their [__] self-esteem comes
from and then they get to you because
I'm used to I did what I do that's
really good yeah I never smoked out of
the building what well I did what the
trans kids do now I go if you don't let
me smoke I'm gonna kill myself
that's what the trans kids do they go
you give me tits from out of here yeah I
would go you have to let me smoke so
they were getting divorced and my
father's like well he's just smoking a
pack
what kind of air freshener you got in a
car right now rifa
[Laughter]
call weeds [__] shut up are you getting
you get the car wash on the regular keep
the car clean yes or no and what are you
whipping around then if you don't mind
us asking what are you Subaru Subaru
okay okay lived in Colorado for 12. sure
yeah you know last week it was raining
in Jersey I could see these jerk laws
doing 30. I'm doing 90 where's you buy
them beep beep vote for me [__]
enjoy your [__] Prius oh we got
electrocuted [__]
wait to get electrocuted you and Tesla
all he is basically being Catholic yeah
yeah when you're a little kid that gets
to you it really does he's told me
[__] whack off with shampoo yeah God
watch me jerk off for an hour he doesn't
like me he's embarrassed of me I think I
got Gray's earlier well it's just
genocides going on
God's pissing me yeah I jerked off on
Easter one time and I was just like
there's no turned off on Easter yeah
dude and I told myself I wouldn't that
was the thing I was like dude I'm dead I
think I got out of a pickle I think you
get into that you might like I think I
like the shame you set parameters you're
like I'm not jerking off this day
I don't need I don't need booze to get
through this event yeah I'm so bad right
now don't expose my cake dude
I really hope I don't have to jack off
on Easter dude the pastel dresses were
out there was like baby blue dresses are
so nice dude sea green I was just like
Jesus Christ yeah The Pastels I was like
discovering new colors being like God I
never saw that color before Jesus Christ
I need to come in my hand
damn I'm gonna go to heaven God's like
he used me to come this whole time
that's [__] up dude I gave up whacking
off for Lent once did you really I will
admit there was something to that yeah
dude dude I just have to this is so
Pilgrim's Journey dude it is there is
something sexual about being like I'm
breaking a deal right now
ugh
like would you tell your folks like what
you gave up for Lynn
[Laughter]
it's my boy it's my son that's what's up
yeah we didn't talk about he's at the
bar you're not gonna believe this my son
gave up jacking off okay you raised him
right if you know we lived across from
that Greek Supermarket which we never
really went to and then there was a
Greek music store yeah across the street
for years and years I remember me and
soda would leave the apartment sometimes
and we go okay I'm going out does
anybody need anything from the Greek
music store does anybody need
does anybody need an olive tambourine
they were selling [__] like that dude
exactly like if there was a funeral home
on the corner that is that turned into a
Starbucks right and soda was like I'm
never going to that Starbucks because it
was a funeral it was a haunted yeah it's
a haunted Starbucks but that's my idea
for like instead of college you know you
just assign a young person to a building
whatever that building becomes is what
that person does okay wouldn't it make
your life more Rich it's like I was a
funeral director now I'm in charge of a
Starbucks
if it becomes a music store or whatever
it becomes a diner it's like you just do
all I have to adjust yeah I love that
it's a great there's you just you
literally just invented feudalism
you take a poor person and you know a
building that a rich person owns and the
rich person decides it's no more a
funeral home learn how to make coffee
you're like yes sir I will do it for my
rations he just
[Laughter]
by the way I like this mic
you know comedy Mothership damn Joe
Rogan
you're about to you're about to get like
uh spend the whole whole lot on this mic
Jesus
better than the [__] Sunset over
there
guys guys can I be real I had a tough
childhood dude tough childhood
you guys wouldn't believe it more than
anything in the entire world me and my
family I mean my siblings we wanted a
dog I'm sure most of you wanted a dog we
were so surprised
when we got a hamster on Christmas but
at that point
we could have eaten anything
[Music]
more I did this
[Applause]
I'll end it there I want you to do it uh
let's let's stop the bear I want to hear
this one more since you were able to do
one joke in your minute
you want to hear this one more all right
well it's not a great one but I did I
did go on a I did go on a vacation guys
I did go on a vacation to a little town
called Paris France
maybe you've heard of it
I got a [__] out of brothel for two
hundred dollars I could get the whole
Shaboom boom here in Austin Texas for
half that City love my ass
oh I can get that also a side of crabs
Tony okay very good very good James I'll
do one more
I'm sorry I'm sorry you guys seem to
really be enjoying this uh I'll give you
a little uh
boom boom but I mean you got two
catchphrases in there two minutes
I'll do one more the whole Shaboom boom
on the back of the shirt
James Pagan you spent 25 seconds talking
about the microphone for no reason
let's just jump right into it uh James
how long have you been doing stand-up
comedy about two months now man two
months where at uh Baltimore and also
here in Maryland
uh oh
shoot wow [__] my ass God damn Jesus
three catchphrases
[__] my ass
oh man did I just call this place
Marilyn
oh I really [__] up the whole movie
but I got one more for you
what is this microphone
Whole Foods don't have a dollar menu
okay yeah slap the Whole Foods in in a
bad neighborhood straighten everybody
out help people out well why doesn't
someone just have a business idea and
just go healthy fast food I think some
of them do they have don't they have
those co-ops like food costs or you can
go and pick up like the ugly but I think
you gotta like Garden or work there or
something like that one day a month or
something but I'm talking about like you
know instead of McDonald's it's like you
know it's like fresh and cold well that
you kind of but nobody puts McDonald's
but but at the top they don't want that
why not because they want to keep
everybody unhealthy and keep them down
tell that totally take over
we're getting real politically yeah I
love how even our political takes are
about fast food they probably on some
level do though right they have to be
because if I was like this staying in
their best interest to have them eating
[__] salads yeah Mickey D's just
dropped the Big Mac sauce you can get it
now in the little thing finally I don't
think that was [__] after years of
letters yeah
now I'm gonna send two letters a day
you did say that like the culmination of
your life
[Laughter]
on to the next cause when I used to get
jobs when I was a kid my friends would
go oh by the way
you gotta steal
because if you don't steal then they
know I was stealing
whether it was a bartending job
because they know he's gonna take the
fall
you gotta steal because they don't know
I was stealing so you got to steal so
now I'm an aspen I'm waiting to get this
and move into this house yeah and I'm
living across the street from his Deli
from his friend's Deli at the time it
was called the in and out house and they
had like curry chicken [__] like that
great sandwiches and he had a friend
that worked in there Steve well I'm
still we still [__] talk 40 years
later we still talk so I kept one night
I'm sitting in front of the hotel
smoking a trailer I'm like I wonder if
you could break into shlomos
I wonder if you could just break that's
how I live my life let me just see if I
could break in there and there was
little window on top of the door bro I
actually and it's on Main Street cops
are driving by I [__] some way or
another I wiggled my way into the window
went in there took the 200 bucks made a
sandwich and leave wow
that's what I was into I was [__]
though I'm three days [__]
do you remember what the sandwich was
chicken curry
I had a friend who uh she uh was a
bisexual Advocate I think and I said no
one gives a [__] yeah yeah and we have
advocates for the guys who you're
[__] we have the kids for the guys
you know because for the trans Community
but the bisexuals we're all kind of
we're all kind of jealous yeah
you've got the pick of the litter yeah
you've got everyone you want my support
all I've got is women yeah
I got your back yeah I'm like but make
sure you bring the kind I like to the
mortgage
the uh yeah Everyone likes you bisexual
women
popular very popular
let it a party go you know who's ruined
in this country those bisexual women
I am an ally I am an ally I'm a bisexual
Ally I will if if you want to have sex
with a man or woman I will be your man
to help you out and get through what
you're going through let me let me march
with you I'm here for you yeah you're
talking real backwards today you're
doing this is going to be a classic
episode because it's your classic
arguments you're only speaking absolutes
and it it just immediately it loses the
Integrity of the argument because it's
no Nuance what are you talking about
what your drink sucks my drink is
awesome what else is there to do to
argue well they're never this no one's
ever done this you'd never find this you
were able to name one place that you
were at two days ago that had a root
beer float on the man no Joe can I name
a specific thing you said diners I'll
say diners too
you're a bad [__] crazy pull up a menu
for here 15 15 best places for rupia
floats in Manhattan Bond Street Lounge
van Lewin ice cream shop one of the best
shops 16 Handles one of the biggest
shops there are Jacob's pickles I just
ate they were Michael J fox listen this
name drop well I did I mean I would have
heard of it
oh nice restaurants Earl Spear and
Cheese Shop okay that's another one oh
yeah
candy shop luncheonette keep going okay
do you Dwayne Park yes do you realize
right Harrison restaurant Meatball Shop
Meatball Shop okay five Napkin Burger
okay Shake Shack has him check also
shakes these places are also have shakes
right you'll play baked by Melissa has
them so major oh well big fight Melissa
has them oh how did I die no so now they
just ached by Melissa has them that's a
huge company bro I don't know so now we
just name 15 places easily in Manhattan
some of them a major change hold on a
second the word and now it's no who
cares hold on a second you did not name
15 places easily you needed a guide that
was curated because people that are
looking for this extinct drink need a
guide to tell them where to find the
goddamn thing
if you Google where to find the best
milkshakes in New York City
won't come up because people know where
milkshakes are you dig article will
still come up
right it didn't require an article but
his point is that the reason that
article exists
anything you say what did you do just
shout louder go to the phones where did
you debunk you just said that you only
reason more frequently than you will
so they're more special to me milkshake
can get everywhere root beer floats are
not as well
the article was made because people need
to go there because they don't know
where to find stand by that okay so that
would mean that milkshake shouldn't have
an article like that because everyone
knows where to get milkshakes no that's
not true right so that debunks your
[__] claim it doesn't debug my click
all right they're not mutually
he named 15 places seven of them are
National chains and all of a sudden
which of those seven were National
chains [__] by the way let's just talk
about shakes
Shake Shack Shake Shack has Ruby uploads
oh really yeah you know why because they
gotta get rid of the [__] vanilla ice
cream nobody wants and they're gonna add
something to the menu
strong that's strong dude they don't
move vanilla shakes they needed to get
rid of the vanilla let's go to the vote
you know when your argument's a horse
[__] right no they're not horseshit the
fact
oh my God
oh my God then let's look it just listed
it let's look oh please there it is
right please please right there it would
have felt so good you know you should do
it so good yeah but it doesn't it
doesn't spell it feels bad right because
you're wrong
you should be filled with negativity I
don't care I'm telling you should feel
bad I'm the only thing I guess the
Creator the only fans at my show in
Miami and and Whitney just gave him my
number so he's like I got a bunch of
chicks here and I was like don't be so
only fans all the time maybe suggest a
restaurant we could go to yeah
but damn did you go I did we were we
were off to the next after the next gig
that'd be fun if you hooked up with a
girl and she's like that'll be 5.99.
you are an open so can I say this and I
mean this sincerely yeah you know how
much we love you I love you your whole
thing
I've been you know paying attention to
it your whole mindset is really [__]
something that I'm striving for I'm
being dead serious well thank you I love
it thank you I appreciate it time and
putting everything in control I really
respect I can't wait to get that text
Monday morning that I hung myself from
my ceiling fan done that before
and I just barely didn't go well with
Father Ted yeah and I can't I can't make
them this is no longer with them
unfortunately I'm not I've seen the new
studio from hell
do you know the password that was
Fidelity
but then what's interesting is that one
time we went to dinner with his family
and his dad was fat shaming him and he
was by no means fat so now I saw like oh
yeah because you came from how did his
dad be like this is how we show love in
my family yeah so his dad would be like
looking a little heavy there like you're
not as thin as you used to be who cares
what are you trying to [__] me Dad
that's what I'd say
it's so weird right yeah yeah like what
do you what do you care like you see
that I'm getting laid right I'm getting
my girlfriend what are you gay you're
the gayest dad anyone's ever had stop
being gay and talking about my weight
but you don't want my gut to hit your
head when you're blowing me yeah yeah
yeah [__] weird dad think about what
you think the most underrated David tell
joke is I mean underrated is hard to say
I guess just favorite yeah he's got a
couple of bangers but one of them is
definitely do you ever have sex with the
the first person you ever had sex with
again oh you don't you want to have yeah
just to show how good you got yeah yeah
look who's not crying like a big boy
that's a great one that is a great bit
what a tag Big Boy also I've told this
affiliate dog but he's got that great
when he goes uh ma'am you like a
vibrator and this lady goes I use my
fingers he goes mmm acoustic
I mean that is genius genius joke oh
he's good and the speed I probably wrote
that 10 years ago he just had in his
back [__] and pulled it right out
well I've told it here 55 times we've
both talked about it but that's the
seller the guy gets up and walks to the
bathroom he goes where are you going the
guy goes nowhere and he goes no I meant
right now
which has to be the funniest off the
cuff line in the history of stand-up
comedy that is the quickest that's like
a meta philosophical joke who was your
Hollywood fictional or real as a person
like Crush when you were a kid
was the first time you saw and you were
like oh my God yo that's so all right
cool so
so fake people it was Jasmine Jasmine
off Aladdin oh my God yeah when I saw
her I was like yo yeah like they're
shooting like this shouldn't exist like
this is so set why is this so sexy I
bought a carpet I was like I'm gonna go
buy a carpet I want to take her on a
ride man
Persian carpet store Persian rugs too or
I had to go buy a carpet I was like in
case I meet this chick I gotta be ready
oh man I need these patterns they have
to
I have to
what about real what about real real
people
um uh Queen Latifah was my first crush
that was your first crush My First Crush
wow to find out that she's not playing
you know our side is crazy just like
Raven smoke you know what I mean it's
like there's no there's no hope there
switch it up and it's it'd be just like
Doja cat like I know that I can't get
what you can get with those your cats no
no no no yes you can yes oh yes you can
yes you can she did an episode of Dave
where they fake fall in love and Dave
wouldn't even let me meet her that was
it they didn't want it didn't even let
me meet her he was afraid because then I
would leave my family for her
you know that you would he knew that if
you would have been next to those that's
right it would have been a [__] rap
it had been over comedy podcasting stats
from May Mike vacchione made the most
guest appearances last month going on a
very respectable five total different
podcasts including we might be drunk
stavy's World Chrissy chaos the Versi
effect and taste buds the most viewed
episode from last month was Uncle Joey
Diaz on flagrant which only came out
nine days ago that episode is currently
sitting at over 1.3 million views be
sure to subscribe to joke world right
now if you're interested in staying in
the comedy Loop and also if you want
these free joke World stickers if you're
interested in these free joke World
stickers there's a link in our bio that
you can click right now fill out that
form and we'll make sure to get you some
in the mail thanks for watching
at joke world
and the world is wrld
[Music]